we look good do we look like around our
periods period sex
you know women Jane what are you doing I
don't even have a vagina that's true
period sex it can get messy but is it
worth it it's debatable
[Music]
and for period sex I am NOT for a period
sex I think if you want to have sex on
your period you should do that I don't
like having ketchup on my hot dog I
think what is gross I'm for period sex
that is my platform I'm arguing for
having sex with a healthy regular
functioning vagina as a female you are
generally more turned on and hornier
when you are on your period if you want
to have sex and you happen to have your
period I don't think there's anything
that should get in the way of that but
if you have like a bloody nose would you
still make out with someone or would you
just wait until your nose stopped
bleeding you're like really into it
would you choose three effects over
normal sex no I think the argument more
is that that you should be able to do it
that year is I could even argue that
blood on your penis is kind of fun
sometimes blood on penis would be quite
quite the mess I mean even if you have a
condom there's no way to get in - out -
like cleaned up without some mess
getting somewhere if there is a mess
you're making that mess every single
time it's only four tablespoons to a cup
that you release during that period I
feel like it's the facts are facts I
mind going sometimes I feel like it's
this much might as well have heard make
the mess once in a while nobody talks
about fluids being a problem when we
talk about squirting I've had sex on my
period you know it got places I didn't
want it to go we got on my pillowcase
and I was like don't want that I haven't
heard the disadvantages yeah I've only
heard you or yeah which to me isn't
really in our you disadvantaged blood on
towels blood on sheets
I mean come on you have a washing
machine Jo I don't think anybody should
tell anybody else their body is yucky
especially if they're trying to [ __ ]
them what about make love
what about make love I'm not a [ __ ]
well that's I don't I'm not a person who
[ __ ] and what are we doing having this
conversation
I see the period as the most creative
week of the month maybe sure let me suck
some nipples or something there's other
things you can do there's other ways
like think about like blushing nipples
is not the same doing a D in your vag
come on ladies we know that it's not
like blood I'm like just upset still
that this happens to me every month if a
girl had made me a turkey sandwich and I
was like oh thanks she's like yeah but
cut my hand I think I bought all over it
I would say oh I'll just I'll just wait
until you make one without blood on it
that sounds better
women aren't here to make you sandwiches
okay the way maybe it's like
conditioning that's made you reject the
idea of periods or a condition it may be
like patriarchal conditioning that's
mangy eject like something natural that
happens in whoa yeah probably you're not
someone I want to have sex with because
like something natural and like very
normal is happening to you and it's like
you know I'm grossed out or like this
makes me squeamish it's like maybe you
shouldn't be having sex maybe our child
to be fair I don't think I sound that
much like a child is it because you
would feel shame you know I just want it
on me like it just grosses me out it's
not that it just it grosses me out
just like getting on stuff and like felt
like I'm like happy about come it is
gross it's sticky and it gets everywhere
then cuz I know that sex is gross and
penises are gross and vaginas are gross
so I don't know even how periods fit
into this he doesn't even want to have
sex against the argument a mess we have
towels we have extra seats we have
showers as a man with glasses the shower
doesn't do it for me I'm a I'm also a
man with glasses I'm at one shower a day
guy and I don't want to end sex and then
and just be covered in crazy fluids and
I think that you're one shower of the
day
the case for period sex is like just the
case for sex really I don't think any
guy should feel ashamed of being a
little grossed out by period blood I I
think you got to grow up and accept it
if you're into it you should do it and
if you're grossed out by things know
yourself as Marilyn Monroe says if you
don't like me when I'm on my period you
don't deserve me did she say that I'm on
my not period did she say that of course
she said that should be with somebody
that thinks that your body is beautiful
that respects the range of the female
experience including menstruation but
you know you can't spell menstruation
without men so I think we can weigh in
on the matter it's natural it's normal
it's a healthy functioning human body
period sex
I'm not really a sex in the morning duh
not a sex in the morning guy not a sex
in the period guy you don't see my good
that fun to have sex with
[Music]